thank you so much
to the organizers for the invitation it
has been a
very stimulating
uh workshop
um so i'll talk about universality for
these uh amp algorithms this is based on
uh some joint recent work with my
colleague professor yuadoo
in the school of engineering um at
harvard and with rish of deja who is
currently
a postdoc working with ua and myself
so rishabh has been
the engine in this
ongoing collaboration and i have been
learning a lot from my collaborators and
i hope to share some of my excitement on
this with you today
so this is the first time i'm talking
about this set of results so if anything
is unclear just stop me and asking
questions okay
okay so let me start with uh a very
concrete simulation
um so what i do is that for some value
of n
i construct a signal vector
where every coordinate i sample from
this
distribution this is a discrete
distribution with some mass at 0 some
mass at 12 and negative 12 some at 20
and oh this should be a negative 20. so
this is symmetric about the origin
and then
given any particular design matrix
note that i'm not
right now saying anything about the
distribution of my design matrix so you
give me any design matrix x i'll
generate my data from the linear model
and then i'll consider
um you know a regularized least squares
estimator in this case i use an elastic
net penalty with parameters lambda 1 and
lambda 2
and i want to study the behavior of this
estimator
and
what i want
to talk about is the behavior of this
estimator under different designs
okay so in particular let me talk about
two specific designs right
the first one um is something that we
refer to as the spike and sign design
so this is a
rectangular design
where okay so what are these objects so
im is an m by m identity matrix
qm is an m by n discrete cosine
transform matrix
so this is a symmetric orthogonal matrix
completely deterministic
and then s here is a
random diagonal matrix
square where the entries are plus minus
one uniform
okay so this is one design
the second design i'll refer to this as
the hard design in some sense so what
this does is that here v
is a random orthogonal matrix
distributed according you know as the
hard distribution so you should think of
it as the uniform distribution on all
orthogonal matrices
and lambda is a deterministic diagonal
matrix
what it essentially okay so in this case
it's a diagonal matrix with m ones and
rest zeros so this is essentially there
so that if i look at the matrix x
you know the covariance matrix of the
first design and the covariance matrix
of the second design these two will be
the same
but that's all that i do okay
now
what i want to draw your attention to is
the fact that
these two designs are very different
in the sense that they're not even off
the same
aspect ratio or dimension they're not
even comparable one is square the other
is a rectangular matrix
the second thing i want to draw your
attention to is the fact that there is
sort of very different levels of
randomness in the designs
so for example the spike and sine
ensemble has only sort of n bits of
randomness coming from these random bits
whereas the har ensemble in some sense i
like to think of it as having order n
square bits of randomness simply because
you can realize a har matrix you know by
constructing a matrix of iid gaussians
and then doing gramschmid on that so
roughly has order n squared bits of
randomness
okay so these are two of them you can
consider many other ensembles
so
ah my plots don't look good i hope okay
so let me explain what i am doing here
so what i hope to convince you of
through these plots is that although
these designs are
fairly different if you look at the
behavior of the
regularized least square estimator
or the dynamics of let's say the
proximal gradient descent algorithm
which solves this
minimization problem they basically
exhibit very similar statistical
properties that's what i hope to
convince you of
so what am i plotting here
so what i'm plotting here is that okay
so on the y-axis i'm plotting the
normalized mse
of the estimator that i obtained
on the x-axis i plot um
so what i do is that i keep changing
lambda 1
which is you know
one of my coefficients
and i keep the ratio lambda 1 to lambda
2 fixed but
i change lambda 1 and i plot the mse of
the estimator as a function of lambda 1.
and i
what i want to show you here is that
i've kind of superimposed
the performance of many different
ensembles
and they basically agree completely
and similarly here what i'm doing is
that i'm plotting the proximal gradient
descent algorithm on the y-axis i have
its mse on the x-axis i'm plotting the
iteration number
yes
but
the if you look at the sample covariance
mistresses then the spectrum are the
same
and the eigenvectors are
in roughly generic position
so
this is sort of um
you know something
that
i would like to explain
let me show you just a couple of other
plots
so what i have here is that again for
some of these different classes of
designs i can look at
the
empirical distribution of the estimator
that i update and here i'm plotting the
histogram of the non-zero entries
and again you see that if as long as the
spectra
are sort of the same
they kind of look exactly the same
now
of course
we are definitely not the first people
to report simulations of this form
as far as i know
some of the very early simulations on
this emerged in
the study of noise less compressed
sensing in the work of donohue and
tanner
management and others
and
donna and tanner also have
results rigorous results about noiseless
compressed sensing but here we are you
know
we are allowing additive noise and we
still see that for a variety of
estimators there's nothing special about
the elastic net case
if you do it for other many other convex
estimators you will see similar behavior
so why why do i um
think it's interesting and worthwhile to
kind of explain this rigorously
so okay first is that intrinsically this
seems like
an interesting observation
but more than that i feel that
to explain this it necessarily motivates
the development of you know theory to
explain this sort of universality
phenomena that
the properties of your statistical
methods or your machine learning
algorithms don't really depend too
heavily on the design
now something that came up in pritham's
talk i think a few days ago is that if
you can rigorously prove such
universality phenomena if you want to
understand your machine learning system
you can basically replace it by a more
tractable analog you can analyze it
rigorously and then basically you know
take that insight back into the specific
system that you care about
okay
so that's why i feel sort of developing
tools to understand such universality
properties is
useful more generically even beyond this
specific example
okay any questions about this particular
simulation setup
okay
so
this is sort of the main takeaway that
if you have these estimators
they often exhibit
very very universal properties as long
as you know sort of you have matching
spectral properties and
you know the the eigenvectors are
in reasonably generic positions
but now okay at this point you might say
well
i might find this interesting but
what does this have to do with
approximate message passing
so i'll come to that in a moment so
please hold on to that thought that will
be sort of one of our main motivations
and and this will be sort of what guides
us in the rest of the talk
i'll probably finish the talk with some
rigorous explanations for the figures
that i started with but i'll come back
to that
okay so what is amp um so we saw some of
this already in ahmed's tutorials and
program also mentioned these algorithms
yesterday
um so i'll i'll still sort of uh go over
it very quickly just to set up some
notation so these are basically
iterative algorithms
so
for example if you have
an instance where you're trying to do an
amp algorithm on a
symmetric square matrix m
you basically do the following procedure
at each step
you take your previous iterations
you apply some
non-linearity coordinate wise so each of
these zero to z t sorry this should be t
plus 1.
so um
each of these zero to z t
these are n length vectors so you stack
them together
you get a matrix
and then you apply this non-linearity
you know row wise to each row
you get some n length vector
then you multiply it with this matrix
and then you do some correction so ahmed
already explained to us what this
correction is and what its role is right
and and this correction is essentially
what
separates
or you know gives amp a very
characteristic nature in the class of
all such uh matrix vector product style
algorithms
so i already explained that ft here is a
non-linearity that supplied coordinate
wise
um and and gt is somewhat of a very
special correction term
it's usually referred to as the memory
term of the onsagar correction in the
statistical physics part
so what is special about gt
um
so
let me come to this in a moment so what
is special about gt is that if you
choose your gt
in a very special way
you have
uh
an empirical convergence of your amp
outputs so specifically if you look at
these vectors if you look at the
empirical distribution then they
converge
to gaussians multivariate gaussians with
mean zero and very specific covariances
and what is even more special is that
typically these covariances can be
explicitly described using a recursive
procedure that is known as the state
evolution
and ahmed already
covered this in the very special case of
the symmetric
wigner or gaussian matrix in his
tutorial
okay so
usually um these amp
algorithms are analyzed and these
theoretical guarantees are derived under
very special distributional assumptions
on the matrix m
okay so in particular um
the the most classical set of
assumptions essentially on this matrix m
whether it be a square matrix or a
rectangular matrix was that its entries
are iid functions mean zero variance
and
these were originally proposed i think
in the physics side in the work of
kabashima and then used in the context
of compressed sensing
again in the work of donohumaleki and
montanari the rigorous proofs emerged in
the work of bayathi montanari and bull
thousand and then there has been a long
line of follow-up work um establishing
rigorous guarantees for these algorithms
um
there has been you know extensions
beyond
the iid gaussian setting
so one way you can generalize the
gaussian setting is to say if you give
me a symmetric gaussian matrix if i look
at its spectral decomposition then i can
write it as some odo transpose and it's
it's not too hard to see that in this
case the matrix o has like a hard
distribution so it's kind of uniformly
distributed on the set of orthogonal
matrices and d
has some empirical convergence you know
in the gaussian case it converges to uh
the semicircle law so you can kind of
generalize from the gaussian case and
you can say okay i'll take m to be of
the form odo transpose o will still be
hard but d in this case will be a
deterministic diagonal matrix i'll
assume that its empirical distribution
converges to a limit this need not be
the semicircle law
this is you know a slightly more general
setting than the symmetric gaussian
matrix ensemble
and even in this case amp style
algorithms have been analyzed
uh
so quite a few of these references that
i have here were emerged from the
physics side and were non-rigorous and
then there has been rigorous results in
the results of
ma ping raman schneider fletcher and
more recently in the work of zofan
so
there
these algorithms have been proposed they
have been analyzed there are rigorous
results for these algorithms
so
why are they useful
um in the context of statistical
learning right
so
the general premise and i'll spend just
one slide um sort of taking
a rather high level perspective here
so why are these algorithms useful
um if i give you any learning problem
um you can either want to you know
analyze a specific estimator which might
not have a closed form but might be in
the form of an erm
or some such implicit description or you
might
want to do bayesian inference and want
to look at the
the posterior distribution and the
the expectations of the one-dimensional
marginals right
um
so
to do this you know if you if i just
gave you this problem you'll roll up
your sleeves and you'll say okay let me
bring out all the tools that i know from
statistical learning high dimensional
statistics probability i have many
different tools to approach this
question so what is rather surprising is
that
this idea of amp has has proved to be
very very useful for a wide variety of
these questions
the general style of this argument is
that
given a certain target estimator or the
posterior mean let's say
you construct an appropriate amp style
algorithm
which in some sense converges to this
estimator of interest
because of the properties that i
mentioned before you can exactly track
the statistical properties of this amp
algorithm and because it now converges
to the estimator of interest you can
kind of transfer these guarantees to the
corresponding
statistical uh procedure right that's
sort of how the argument goes
so this is the general style um in which
ap algorithms have been used in various
statistical problems and machine
learning
questions and this sort of also goes
back to
the the approach that program adopted in
her talk yesterday you know how this was
used in the context of causal influence
um so i think
given this entire discussion
um
one very natural
conclusion that you might reach is that
okay this class of amp algorithms
seems to give me very very precise
properties of the estimators that i want
to study but at the cost of making very
very strong distributional assumptions
on the problem
so i might need to make a very strong
assumption that my design entries are
iid standard gaussians or you know some
very specific form and only then i get a
very precise characterization
and so you might say okay this is good i
get a lot of theoretical insights
but
maybe i don't really believe my design
is gaussian right maybe i don't believe
my features have certain orthogonally
invariant properties
what happens then
so what i'd like to
do today is to kind of
complement that
in some sense push back on that
conclusion slightly
and i'd like to
provide a complimentary
perspective or a complimentary
application of this idea okay
so what i'd like to argue today is that
amp algorithms as such are
remarkably universal
to the distribution of your ensemble
they don't really care as much they're
very robust
and therefore
because these algorithms can be used to
track a variety of statistical
estimators
the properties of the estimators will
also be universal
and
essentially amp algorithms and their
universality can be
sort of a way to get at the universality
of the estimators that you care about
that's sort of the perspective that i'm
going to adopt
i'll spend most of the talk today
talking about universality of amp and
and get at the second part only at the
very end very briefly but if you're
interested i'm happy to talk about this
offline
any questions so far
okay great
so okay
the fact that amp algorithms for example
don't really require
gaussianity
for the matrix ensembles for example
this has been known for for a while now
so the first result in this direction
was by
uh mats and barati mark le large and
montenari in 2015 and later by waco chen
and waikitlam
last year
so they basically prove a result of this
form and this is sort of the notion in
which i'll always talk about
universality so let me parse through the
result right
so they say suppose you consider any amp
algorithm of the form that i mentioned a
few slides ago
and assume that your non-linearities are
smooth and smooth here means let's say
lip shades or pseudo lip shits in the
sense that ahmed described
assume that you have this symmetric
square matrix its entries let's say are
independent or iid
mean zero variance one and sub gaussian
so they have sufficiently light tails
so if that's the case then the amp
outcomes are universal in the sense that
if you take two different matrix
ensembles m i j and m tilde i j and if
you run the same set of algorithms and
if you get two sets of outputs
if you apply some reasonably nice test
function f and if you look at the
empirical averages they converge to the
same value
so what this means essentially is that
for example if you use these algorithms
as estimators if you look at the
reconstruction error whatever is the
reconstruction error under one ensemble
will be the same as that under the other
ensemble
this result by itself tells you nothing
about what the actual answer is
it only tells you that the answer is the
same in whatever ensemble you choose
but then the advantage is that you know
how to calculate the answer in the
gaussian ensemble so that's sort of this
integrable example in your family so
once you know the example in the
gaussian case you know the answer in
every other
uh wigner ensemble that you have yeah so
just to clarify um
so
mij is like the design matrix chosen
ahead of time right yeah so this is
basically saying that
um
is it basically saying that like you
might as well just choose it to be a
gaussian matrix because in terms of the
properties like if you just care about
analyzing let's say the reconstruction
error of a regularized least squares
estimator
in under these assumptions if you know
that
the entries can only be iid mean zero
variance bonds of gaussian let's say
then
you might as well choose a construction
choosing the matrix in it in a different
way maybe have some other effect
like that's not related to the
convergence of the empirical means like
because my question is like does this
necessarily say that there's not really
like a smart way to choose matrix
um
so in terms what it says is that in
terms of the answer you get the same
answers but it could be for example okay
so i don't know of a concrete example
that i can give you right now but it
could be for example that for one of
these you know if you wanted to really
calculate what this answer is there
could be some other ensemble for which
calculating this answer was much easier
than the gaussian case
so
if there were some such thing and if you
could cleverly choose a different
ensemble maybe you could calculate the
answer more easily
all questions
okay
so this was this was nope
but
one restriction of this class of
universality results is that it
it basically tells you that gaussianity
let's say isn't really important but it
doesn't really reduce the amount of
randomness in the problem
it still basically says okay you go from
one ensemble with order n square bits of
randomness to another ensemble with
order n square bits of randomness the
answer stays the same
the question is okay what happens
if you move to more structured cases can
you actually have
ensembles with much less randomness that
basically exhibit the same
and if you remember
in our initial simulations
we had this spike and sign
ensemble that basically had only order n
bits of randomness but still seem to
exhibit the same kind of property right
so that's what we are interested in
so what i'll do
for the main part of the talk today
is to introduce this family of what we
call semi-random matrices
and i'll analyze a very simple
class of amp algorithms
and i'll exhibit that um
these amp algorithms are universal for
all these semi-random ensembles
so
my choice of the amp algorithm will be a
simple choice but that's just for
convenience in in follow-up work we've
been able to generalize it to a broader
class of algorithms but for the purposes
of the talk i'll restrict myself to a
simple case
the main
ideas that i hope to communicate are the
notions of semi-random matrices
what they buy us
and why we are able to prove this
universality
that's sort of the main goal for me
today
and
throughout the talk basically
universality will be in the sense that i
described in the last slide sorry so two
classes of things if they have the same
properties if you run amp algorithm on
any two such ensembles you will get the
same output
that's the style of results i'm going
for
okay so
the the class of algorithms that i look
at
are these
so-called memory-free amp algorithms
these particular ones were introduced
by chapman and oper
and and their validity was later
established in the follow-up work by
zofan a couple of years ago
so what what these are algorithms with a
very specific flavor what are they doing
so they basically say
you again update your algorithms these
are basically like okay you have zt
you apply some non-linearity coordinate
wise to this vector you multiply it with
some matrix m
and effectively that we would like to
call that to be zt plus one
but there is some small thing that you
have to correct here i'll come back to
this in a bit uh yeah this is this is
not really that important you should
really think of it as an algorithm that
i get by taking a vector applying a
non-linearity multiplying by a matrix
sine of the algorithm
okay
so what why why this specific choice
so
if you go back and think about it when i
initially introduced the amp algorithm
there was a certain correction term
right the onsagger correction that i
described what is special about this
particular class of algorithms is that i
don't need to worry about the
observatory
that's what's special
now we also know how to handle cases but
there is a correction term so so we can
talk about that as well but i'll
restrict myself to this class of
algorithms for simplicity
right in some sense because so so
roughly this this leads to what is
called the divergence free criteria i'll
come to that in a few slides so
essentially the idea is
uh
you want to assume that f is
yeah so exactly the projection of f
uh on the gaussian space to gaussians
with a very specific variance that has
to be zero on the first hermit
polynomial that's basically what this is
to do
okay
so this is the algorithm
this is the most important
notion i hope you'll take away from the
slide today okay so
there's a few different uh notions out
here so let me go over it very slowly
and if anything is unclear please do
stop me okay
so the ensemble that i'll consider you
know this is our class of semi-random
matrices
so we want m to be of the form s psi s
right
s will be
the random part in our description this
is the same the random part of the
semi-random ensemble
so it's a diagonal matrix
every entry is iid plus or minus one
okay
um
the the matrix psi here will be
completely deterministic so the ensemble
has only order n bits of randomness
and then
i'll make some structural assumptions on
the
matrix sign
so specifically what i'll assume is that
the matrix itself is delocalized
roughly at the order 1 over root n
the operator norm is of order one
and essentially what conditions three
and four tell you is that
if you look at the matrix psi psi
transpose
then it basically has to look like
a diagonal matrix
with all equal entries on the diagonal
in the l infinity norm that's roughly
what three and four are telling us
okay so
roughly what three and four are telling
us is that if you look at psi psi
transpose
minus
some constant sigma psi squared
times identity
if you look at
the l infinity norm of this then this
has to be small
okay so i
write it differently so let me just say
this is small
because i have slightly different
requirements on what happens on the
diagonal and the off diagonal
but this is roughly what this is saying
entry-wise yeah so that's why you know
here i have off-diagonal lenses we take
the meat you know the maximum of them
the diagonal entries
so i have i don't really need any rate
of convergence on the diagonal entries
but the off diagonals i need something
basically like one overlooked
so why do you expect a smaller first
word can be infinity
any questions regarding this definition
this is sort of the only uh
thing that i hope you will take away
from this talk
okay
so
our main result um one of our main
results that i hope to talk about today
is that
if your matrix ensemble m
is semi-random
and if your non-linearities are smooth
enough
and if you start from some iid
initialization
then your outputs will be universal
so what this is roughly saying is that
if you start from some iid
initialization
for any two semi-random ensembles
uh you will basically get the same
answer
provided you know these two ensembles
have the same value of sigma psi squared
this is great
does this mean if i look at a
optimization problem
yeah on plus minus one on the hypercube
and i look to maximize
the sk model but for that
yeah so for example one of our
applications we do it a bit in our paper
but so one of the main applications for
example that
uh opera and chuck had when they looked
at this was
they so there was some prior work in
physics by parisi and potter's and crazy
marinarian retort i think where they
looked at you know uh sk type models
with very deterministic couplings
and using uh
music simulations they had basically
predicted that these models should also
exhibit the same properties as escape of
you know sk like in some sense so you
get the same value
right as lo so the only caveat here is
that physicists didn't have the sign
we still need to sign things
so on the signed version
we do get so
and and i can come back later to whether
you need signing or not that's something
we've been thinking about quite a lot
recently but
at that level
so how should i think of the condition
on psy is it like
should i think of this as roughly
sort of a diagonal uh
sort of d1 being roughly similar
right now so hopefully that will clarify
other questions
so here are a few examples i'll do a few
examples
so one example it here is that if you
have a matrix psi which is a symmetric
orthogonal matrix
and if this is delocalized
then if you sign it then you get a
semi-random ensemble
um so for example if you have like a
discrete cosine transformer discrete
sine transform
a hadamard walsh matrix these are
deterministic matrices
um you take them you sign them you will
get the same
that's that's one
direct application
the second one is and this is sort of
what we are really going for
um so
one sort of
so one of the ensembles that i described
before
where matrices of the form
od or transpose
where d is a deterministic diagonal
matrix and o is hard right and i told
you that this one example people really
understand well
so what i'm saying here is that
you don't really need o to be hard
okay this is not really important
as long as
the the eigen basis is sort of a
delocalized matrix for example if it's
just sine and permutation in variant
you'll still have the same kind of
properties
so har isn't really
important
much less randomness still will give you
the same results
and then
one of the applications so
when chakmak and oper applied their amp
algorithms
uh
in co so there's a slight difference
from the algorithm that ahmed presented
in this tutorial they don't so both
thousands algorithm
um works directly on the matrix
uh j in some sense
but um
chuck mark and opera's algorithm works
on the resolvent
rather than just on
the matrix
but
doesn't really matter
if you take this symmetric matrix
as long as you know square root n j i j
has finite moments of all orders
uh if you look at these resolvents these
are centered resolvents
you will get still
have the semi-random property
so there is one
slight issue here because of the signing
i need to assume that
jij and has is symmetric about
zero i don't think this should be
required i think this is an artifact of
our proof but
morally this is sort of what it tries to
get
so to prove a matrix ensemble is saying
around them you just multiply it by
diagonals on both sides and that showed
that that has a small spectral norm
that's sort of why we can verify it so
for example i think i think the heaviest
machinery we need is actually for the
iod ensemble because to show the kind of
relocalization thing we really need to
rely on like recent advances in random
matrices like
local versions of uh
of you know matrix results and stuff
like that
but the others are actually the
concentration
so it's fairly easy i would say to
verify it
assuming that neutralization is causing
the
kind of higher
function
yeah so so right we realize this after
we put our paper out which kind of
in hindsight seemed a bit stupid but uh
the thing is you one of our restrictions
is that we can
apply only the same function to every
chord right so i could rephrase my
result to say that i start from a
constant initialization
that's kind of one of the things but
you're right if i if i apply a lipschitz
function then i can generalize
the class of laws you know iid laws from
which i start so there is nothing very
specific about joshua i can introduce an
initial iteration and change things
but i i stated it in the form of
[ __ ] because as you would see that's
kind of used in our proof so i wanted to
state in that form
okay
any questions
okay so
let me spend
maybe the next 10 minutes
uh giving you some ideas for the proof
uh
so the proof essentially has you know
three steps
of which i think basically the third
step is the real challenge
the first one is to basically say that
um
essentially say that if i can do it for
some functions that have some special
properties along the lines of what song
i needed to a while back so if these are
like divergent screen
i'm basically done
and the second step is basically like a
normalization step and an approximation
step basically saying okay i am applying
these
non-linearities if i can do the proof
for polynomials i'm basically done
uh and okay some other normalizations
that we've seen
the the critical step in this entire
proof
was uh
the proof with when once you have done
all these normalizations how do you go
about it
and we'll say that the main workhorse
for us is like a method of movement
style argument along the lines of what i
meant already mentioned uh earlier this
morning
uh
but but there are some supplements there
i hope to i'll do a very simple case but
i also hope to tell you briefly about
what the challenge is
okay so
what is this this term essentially doing
um
so
suppose um
suppose you're willing to assume
and i'll do it inductively so this is
okay
suppose i have done everything up to you
know time t right if i have done
everything up to time t
then i basically know that
z t is empirically like a gaussian with
zero and variance sigma t i already know
so if i know that then i know that this
term basically behaves like sigma p
square
and if i look at this inner product then
it basically behaves like sigma t times
expectation
where z is a standard function
so effectively what it says is that this
term is like m times some function f
tilde where f tilde satisfies this
divergence
so the reason i didn't start with this
description is that it requires me to
tell you
if what this sigma t is but it's
basically what you get out of state
evolution
so
so the first simplification that i'll do
is to say okay hence what i'll assume
that my algorithm is of the form zt plus
1 is m f tilde t where f tilde satisfies
this divergent speed condition
um
the second step okay let me not even
talk much about it i'll basically assume
that these non-linearities can be
replaced by polynomials
ah that i think everyone here can
believe
um another thing i'll also assume is
that okay i said that
the diagonal entries of psi phi
transpose need to be close to sigma psi
squared so i'll assume that okay they're
exactly all equal to sigma psi squared
that also introduces a vanishing error
that you can track
and then you can do some normalization
so you can set that sigma psi squared is
one and sigma zero squared is one that
like introduces some scaling that you
can
adjust later
and finally i'll also do so you know
i'll also assume that these
non-linearities which are now
polynomials they basically have our unit
norm with respect to standard gaussians
and that's essentially also just a
normalization
but what they advise us is that it now
gives us a very specific target
once you
allow me to make these three assumptions
i can conclude from the state evolution
equations that now i'm basically trying
to prove that zt is a mean zero variance
one gaussian
once you allow me these
these
normalizations
i know what my target is and that
becomes crucial
uh
okay so now
okay i'll do it for the unit marginal
case
i'll do the most obvious thing i'll
prove that if you want to analyze
what happens to this empirical average
you just need to analyze what happens to
the expectation
and this will follow just by some
out of the box concentration inequality
reference time something like that and
the expectation here is just with
respect to the random signs and the
randomness of the initialization those
are the only two things that we have
here
right
um so why did i make a big deal of the
normalization step two slides ago
because now i know that these zips are
basically going to behave like standard
functions
so to to do this step where i have to
analyze this empirical average i will
only do it for polynomials and in
particular i'll do it for hermits
the advantage of doing it for hybrid
polynomials is that we do this analysis
in a method of movement style so i'll
know precisely what targets are moving
if i did it normally i needed to match
it to moments of the gaussian that's
somewhat more complicated i'll instead
show everything goes to z
just helps you
okay so
let me do a very simple example um
so suppose my test function is just x
and f so i'll go up to the second
iteration
and let's say f1 and f2 are these two
functions okay
you can check that they satisfy whatever
assumptions i needed these are
polynomials things are nice
so
okay what do i do i start with my
average
i unroll the operations i expand it
and i eventually get some expansion in
terms of the matrix entries and the
initialization
okay great this is also what ahmed
mentioned earlier today
now what you do is that you take the
expectation right you take the
expectation with respect to the signs
and you take the expectation with
respect to the initialization
so the mij's contain the signs and the z
knots are iid gaussians
once the dust settles you just have some
expression
in terms of the entries of your
localized matrix size
that's what you mean
and now for example i would i would need
to prove um that this thing actually
converges to zero right that's what i
would prove
so in this particular case um
i can get lucky in that i can basically
bound this by a crude triangle
inequality bump i just
bound every term
by an absolute value
and then i have the localization
estimate turn by turn
and other things range
but this is sort of
really special this doesn't happen
always
the problem is that when you do this
unrolling operation in general
and once you express everything in terms
of the initialization z naught
you're gaining polynomial numbers of
terms at each step right
so if you are not careful
and if you
just put a crude
absolute value bound
at this step sometimes and in most cases
actually
the the polynomial growth in the number
of terms that you have will kill you
um and these decays that you get from
individual terms they don't really
give you enough gain right
so what we have to do is to actually
crucially track what happens with the
cancellations and we re crucially here
use the fact that psi psi transpose
essentially looks like some constant
times identity this is where that comes
into the picture so you have some
cancellations coming from the terms
where things converge to a diagonal
entry you have some things you know some
cancellations coming from the fact that
of diagonal entries of size i transpose
are close to zero so we have to kind of
track that and we have some
combinatorial scheme to actually get at
that
so this
you know what i have here on this slide
is slightly misleading it gives you the
sense of
you know what we want to do but
this strategy does not work in general
so what works
yeah so we we have to kind of keep track
of these so
what what ends up happening is that once
we extend things we still track it in
terms of these decorated trees
and then
these cancellation operations that i
mentioned they come up as
combinatorial operations on the tree
so for example the fact that psi phi
transpose diagonal entries are one
when you sum up those things in terms of
the tree we can visualize it as you know
you have two of these leaf
you know sister leaf nodes you kind of
collapse them so you prune the tree
so you kind of prune the tree and in
some cases you like do some
cancellations
we have some scheme to keep track of it
combinatorially but but once you do that
the cancellation does happen this this i
think was
the step that was actually a bit magical
for us
when we did this
any any questions
comments
okay
so
now
um
sort of
parallel to what we did
um
sort of a
very close to when when our initial work
in this direction came out there was
also
uh an independent approach for
universality of these algorithms uh that
was introduced by chiang hao wong shin
so they have they actually have a
slightly different approach
um
there are some
okay so what do they do they have they
analyze both
universality for
amp algorithms with iid matrix entries
and for these orthogonally invariant
classes so they do both
for the iid setting
they actually improve the existing
results
quite a lot and they prove that you know
even if the entries are even if the
matrix
is the adjacency matrix of some sparse
random graph
with diverging degrees and things like
that so very general ignore matrices you
still have the same result so i think
this definitely fills in a very
important gap in the existing literature
um
i think the
the there are some slight differences
between the two approaches when it comes
to these orthogonally invariant designs
so we are still
trying to understand what the
similarities and the differences are
at a high level there is some similarity
because they also do
an unrolling kind of operation so they
expand things out and then do a
combinatorial step so
at that level think these two approaches
seem to be a bit similar
but so far as we understand there are
some crucial differences in particular
i think their approach crucially
utilizes the randomness in the matrix
rather than in the initialization
and as a result they they in some cases
need
more randomness than what we can handle
okay so for example the semi-random
ensemble that i described to you
is actually much less random than sort
of a competing class that they have
but
as an upshot uh their combinatorial
analysis can be a bit more streamlined
so
uh i think these are these are two
parallel lines of work and i think it
would be very interesting to see how
they compare with each other moving
forward in terms of
you know when they can be used
so
this is a parallel work
uh
i'll take two minutes and tell you about
okay i'll revisit the initial simulation
um
to basically say you know why are these
connected so let's go back to our
regularized least squares problem
and basically um
what we can prove and this is this is
actually a very new result hopefully it
will come out an archive today or
tomorrow hopefully soon
so what we can prove using the same
style of analysis
is that
okay so you have your
design matrix in regression
you express it as some j times s so s is
this sign that i need
j is a deterministic matrix
and what i'll assume is that if you look
at the matrix j transpose j raised to
the power k
then it's close to some constant times
identity for every k
okay and this constant essentially is
the kth moment of some measure so you
should think of this measure as
the limiting spectral distribution of
the sample covariance matrix right
and uh putting this condition for every
k is sort of like putting it on the
matrix resolvent
but we just found this form to be
slightly easier to work with i think it
should be possible to go between one
form and the other
at a very high level our result
basically says that
if the loss that we are looking at is
strongly convex
then we can use these amp universality
results to basically conclude that
restricted least squares estimators will
also be universal
and you can get this strong convexity
either if the regularizer that you have
is strongly convex or if you have you
know
if your problem least squares part is
well conditioned
you'll get this
um
right i don't have it right now
um and i can expand more on that i don't
have it yet
um
because it it requires us to prove
something about the state evolution
equations and the uniqueness
um
[Music]
so but but if it's elastic net and stuff
you're okay in the initial simulations
that i showed you actually
we ran elastic net but with the
ridge part very very small like 10 to
the minus 3 or something and you
basically still see the same thing so i
think it's
going to be the same
but formally i don't have a proof
so to conclude
basically the main takeaways are that
you know
amp algorithms are quite robust they
don't really depend too much on the laws
of these ensembles that you work with
the the strong distributional
assumptions that we see in practice or
you know see
at first are basically there to let us
characterize their properties
and the fact that these algorithms can
be used to track
statistical estimators can allow us in
fact to take these guarantees for amp
style algorithms and transfer them to
the
statistical estimators that we care
about
um we did this in the context of the
linear model i think it would definitely
be interesting to go beyond this
structure
and to actually handle what happens for
base posteriors
uh and okay there is this question that
has been gnawing at us which is do we
need the signing what happens if you
have completely deterministic ensembles
we have some preliminary thoughts on
this i'm happy to expand more on it but
that's sort of where we are thank you so
much for your attention
sk
and the same doesn't matter you can just
change it
we thought of this there was
there was some annoying issue which
which still bothered us i think it was
because
okay so we were looking at the uh the
the amp algorithm that tries to get to
the solution to the tap equations right
and that no longer works just on the
hyper cube that like works on the solid
queue
so there was some difficulty related to
that that's why we kind of ended up
still giving that assumption
um but but i i kind of view it more as a
as a technical barrier and what we did
um
yeah i think i think one question that
we find actually really
intriguing is okay what happens if you
don't have the signings at all
and whether it is possible to replace
these signs by additional assumptions on
the deterministic part
um
also you said you can generalize this to
the
[Music]
the algorithms that we need to consider
uh
what we do is that we can handle history
now
so if you have history you can kind of
encode
uh
you can encode the correction terms
so that sort of really helps us simplify
things
uh it it it kind of um
so what what happens is that if you have
history then when you do the
combinatorial analysis that becomes a
bit more complicated down the line
but at least in this linear model
setting that still is attractive so i
think
going beyond that
one needs to see
yes